in those months when i was pregnant
all around this same time
so we have in tandem the conversation of
he won't be
given security he's not going to be
given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
regarding those conversations about
archie's skin tone
what was the overall reaction on that
side of the pond
i mean it's just been it it's it's
shocking uh
it's been received with as much shock
and disbelief
here this side of the pond as it has in
america i mean the suggestion is very
clear
the suggestion is that there is racism
within the institution i mean that is a
huge
and explosive allegation to make
he did not share the identity with me
but he wanted to make sure that i knew
and if i had an opportunity to share it
that it was
not his grandmother mother nor his
grandfather
that were a part of those conversations
it would point
very glaringly towards charles then not
surprisingly
this allegation has been picked up
around the world
um it has turned into a very ugly race
row
um which the monarchy has found itself
right
at the center of course we have to wait
to see where they're going to respond to
those allegations
i think prince harry has quickly
realized the seriousness of it
oprah was told to make it clear um to
gail king that it wasn't
the queen or the duke of wenber who is
of course ill and recovering from heart
operation
in hospital at the moment but of course
it's opened up a pandora's box and there
is something now the witch hunt to find
out
which royal it is and you know the
suggestion is that
if it's charles if it's william and
that's a very big if
no one knows it's pure speculation which
is the problem with that answer
then that you know that has real
repercussions for the monarchy
charles is going to be the next king
after that william
does that haunt charles in many ways
whether he said it or not
does that insinuation now haunt charles
well to be honest i don't think it
really matters which member of the royal
family said it it's the fact that
a member of the royal family expressed
those
views and who is almost irrelevant
the concerning thing is is that someone
felt that way
i never thought that i would have my
security removed because i was
born into this position i inherited the
risk so that was a shock to me
that was what completely changed the
whole plan why would the palace be so
insistent on removing security for a
position that
as harry said he inherited prince harry
from the day he was born has had a close
protection officer who has
been by his side every minute of every
day
that that was his his birthright
as a working member of the royal family
that was what he was entitled to
when he and megan decided that they were
going to stand down
as senior royals they lost
that security detail they were no longer
public servants therefore they didn't
get
the taxpayer-funded security detail they
were essentially
cut adrift and that's not the royal
family being
mean over here in britain if they were
continuing to get
british taxpayer-funded security and the
royal family would have come under huge
fire
they weren't here working in britain
they were living in canada
and then they moved to la it was their
decision to stand down and therefore
security then became their
responsibility
at the end of the day the average brit
how do they feel about
that moment because it was a moment that
made people gasp
what is what is how are
how are they viewing the monarchy today
because that
you know you're you're talking about a
country that a commonwealth
that is very very diverse these claims
have come
on commonwealth day a day that is
incredibly important to the queen she's
very proud
that she presides over so many
multi-racial
realms and countries and there is there
is a feeling of shock
over here at these allegations a feeling
of disbelief
um and certainly among some commentators
uh and some parts of the public who are
clearly very divided
on social media um a huge amount of
offense
that that the queen the institution the
royal family is being accused of
racism and when you know the queen
simply it has to be said
is not racist how do they handle this
because we know
that historically the palace just likes
to stay mum
but can they in this situation well
the queen's mantra has always been never
complain
never explain i think the palace were
hoping and certainly newspapers were
being briefed over the weekend
that this would just be a storm that
flew over given time
i think we've all realized on both sides
of the pond
that this storm is not going to go away
anytime
soon a can of worms has been opened some
very serious things have been said
and i think the palace really have no
choice but to
issue some sort of a comment does the
palace also miss that they don't have a
face that can
just look you know in the past
these have been very kind of
stiff two five ten line statements
will this change will someone come out
and talk like a human being to
other human beings for once it's not the
queen's way to wear her heart on her
sleeve
and i i actually think it should be
pointed out that in
in some of the statements that we have
seen released
by buckingham palace which had clearly
got the queen's stamp on it
a sense of real empathy a sense of love
a sense of affection that we are not
used to seeing
or hearing from the queen i think she
has been very generous
in her recognition of the couple we
don't know if we're going to get a
statement
we have no idea how that will be worded
but
i think the queen is very in touch with
the tone
and the mood of the nation and and she i
think she will know exactly how
how to address that